l'arrestation de Britney grinner avait
provoqué une onde de choc aux États-Unis
et dans le monde du sport cela faisait
des mois que Washington négocient en
coulisse ses libération la basketteuse
de 32 ans avait été arrêtée puis
emprisonné à Moscou le 17 février
dernier pour trafic de drogue
aujourd'hui est une bonne journée dit sa
conjointe qui a maintenu la pression
pendant 9 mois auprès du gouvernement
américain
c'était un moment sombre de ma vie
dit-elle et je n'ai que de la gratitude
envers le président
les négociations ont été intenses et
douloureuses affirmer un Joe Biden
soulagé
[Musique]
elle est en sécurité dit-il et en route
pour la maison Britney cryner avait été
arrêté à l'aéroport de Moscou une
semaine avant l'invasion russe en
Ukraine elle avait en sa possession une
vapoteuse et du liquide contenant du
cannabis
voilà ce que je suis
de la persécution politique dit le
sénateur démocrate Durban elle allait
passer plus de 9 ans dans une prison
russe elle a été libérée en échange d'un
redoutable trafiquant d'armes russe
proche du Kremlin Victor boots
surnommait le marchand de la mort il
purgeait une peine de 25 ans de prison
depuis 2008 aux États-Unis